hi i'm jennifer evans cario the
president of sugar spun marketing and
the social media faculty chair at market
motive thanks for joining me for part
one in my introduction to social media
marketing series
while most people are familiar with
social media when it comes down to the
idea of social media as it relates to
business and marketing there's still a
lot of people in the world that are a
little bit confused in terms of how it
really fits and why it is that it really
works at its most basic level social
media is about people connecting with
each other they're connecting to share
thoughts resources media links deals
generalized conversation it basically
takes the smaller amount of one-to-one
communication we have in our everyday
life and it opens it up to almost an
infinite amount of contact potential
that happens when communication spread
across the globe
social media represents an enormous
market people are turning to the social
web to the point that the social web is
actually becoming the web social media
is no longer just a small part of
marketing social media is one of the
primary ways in which marketing and
communication happens between companies
and individuals
when we talk about who's using social
media there's still a common
misconception within the business world
that it's the younger crowd it's the
younger audience that's coming in but in
the last several years we have seen such
an explosion of the reach of social
media that it's really getting to the
point where there is no single age group
that really dominates social media we
see really really strong numbers spread
across almost all demographics including
that 65 plus demographic that is
flocking to sites like facebook in
droves
now when we look at the amount of time
that's spent on social media we can
quickly begin to see that social media
sites are becoming the primary place
that people invest their time when
they're going online
sites like facebook where a user
averages 423 minutes of time on site per
month
youtube 300 minutes of time on site per
tumblr um a popular micro blogging site
for the people who go there it's 151
minutes per month pinterest users
average about 80 minutes per month and
twitter users average about 25 minutes
per month people are going to these
sites into these services as their
starting point to their interface with
the web and then they're traveling out
into the web to read articles to look at
resources to do their shopping and
that's heavily influenced by the
references the sharing the content that
they're picking up when they're on these
social media sites interacting with
other people that they're connected to
now when we look at why social media is
so important from the business
perspective it's really important to
understand that social media has done
this amazing job of taking sort of an
age-old business concept and putting it
to work today
way way way back when in the days of
main street usa where you didn't have
chains and you didn't have these big box
retailers
people went and shopped at stores where
they knew the owner and the owner knew
the customers and there was a really
good connection between the consumer and
the business owner in terms of what they
were looking for you know what sold well
with them what really resonated with
them but as we moved into this area of
franchises and again big box retailers
there became a disconnect between the
businesses and the customers what social
media has done is bring us back around
to the point where we can make those
connections again
social media brings businesses and
consumers together
in a way that hasn't been possible since
we moved out of that realm of small
individual stores individual businesses
people serve as the foundation of social
media people that are sharing ideas and
opinions and asking questions and
providing feedback
it gives companies the ability to
observe and listen to consumers to see
what they're interested in and what is
the driving and motivating force behind
the actions that they take and the
conversions that they make and then
finally it humanizes an entity so again
it gives these huge mega corporations
the chance to have a personality
associated with them to be accessible to
be a company that really is interested
in listening to people and when people
have a choice of where they can go to do
business and now they have a choice that
extends all over the world thanks to the
internet it almost forces companies into
that position of allowing themselves to
be humanized and allowing themselves to
interact on a different basis so that
people can see the value of doing
business with them
now on the last slide we talked a little
bit about the idea of social media
bringing businesses and consumers
together the thing that's important to
understand is that consumers are going
online to hunt for information before
they buy a car or a tv or a dishwasher
or even a book or a movie they want
feedback they want information and
they're no longer forced to live in that
world where they just walk up to the
people they know and say hey have you
bought this yet what do you think of it
they can actually go out and look at
sort of the collective group think of is
this a popular movie is this a popular
car and not only is it popular but why
is it popular what do people think about
it they can go to social media and they
can ask for information and people will
provide them links and data and videos
and reviews and they can get as much
insight from owners of the product as
they want now at the same time brands
are looking for consumers they're trying
to figure out who their target audience
is they're trying to figure out where
they can connect with them where they
can get their message out to them and
even what type of message is going to
resonate with them the great thing about
social media is there's this explosion
of happiness and potential on all sides
when the consumer and the brand need
each other in this space because the
consumer has gotten the information they
need and the brand has been able to get
that feedback from the consumer to be
able to deliver exactly what they're
looking for
now we mentioned that people are the
foundation of social media there's a
process that happens as people get
involved with the brand online and they
start to do the research and they get
exposure to a potential brand and they
make the choice to become a customer and
from there if things go well for you you
have the potential for that customer to
become an endorser someone who turns
around and says oh yeah that was a great
product i really like that
above and beyond the endorser you've
also got the potential to turn them into
an evangelist someone who takes every
opportunity given to them to sing the
praises of your product or your company
because they've had such a wonderful
experience with you that foundation that
is built from the interactions you have
with consumers online that's the word of
mouth potential that can really really
take your business to a whole new level
social media is also going to give you
the chance to observe and listen to go
and find consumers where they are listen
to what they're talking about and really
understand what it is you need to
deliver whether that's everyday chatter
of just seeing what your target audience
is interested in and talking about or
maybe it's specific feedback about you
or one of your competitors maybe it's an
expressed need if you're going okay this
is a target audience this is an
individual and they actually need what
it is i have to offer so how can i
figure out how to get that message in
front of them
it's basically a non-stop focus group
for you it's a focus group of people who
don't always realize that they're even
being listened to so they're being very
open and honest about their opinions and
it's a great chance for you as a company
to come in and gather up that data and
figure out what you want to do with it
social media humanizes a company as i
mentioned a couple slides ago it's about
taking these big nameless faceless
corporations and saying you know what
yes we're big but let's say hey because
we're big we've got great prices we have
great availability you know you can walk
into our store all across the country or
even in multiple countries and take a
look at our products and pick them up
and feel them but at the same time we
have a personality behind us we want to
connect with you we want to deliver
exactly what you want and therefore we
can use something like social media to
help you be able to connect with us in a
more effective way
now the big warning that i want to give
you for social media because
unfortunately this is something a lot of
marketers a lot of pr types and
especially a lot of c-suite types forget
when they go into social media people
are not there to sell or buy your
products people are on social media to
interact with other people that they
either know offline or that they've
connected with online because of a
shared interest that doesn't mean that
you can't get them to sell or buy your
products to other people just means that
you have to understand that's not their
focus and therefore you're going to have
to get very creative in your approach to
be able to present things in a way that
motivates them to get involved with your
company
coming up in part two of this series
we're going to talk about the various
social media channels and what some of
the differences are between them but
we're also going to get a little bit of
word of warning on the need to be
selective so as you're getting ready to
go through the rest of the course again
make sure that you understand the
overall ideas of social media and you
can really look objectively at some of
these different channels to figure out
which ones are going to be the best fit
for you